just when you thought there wouldn't be
another javascript framework along comes
another javascript framework this one's
called hydrogen and it's a react-based
framework for building custom e-commerce
sites using shopify it's focused on
server-side rendering kind of like next
js but comes with a bunch of pre-defined
components and hooks to manage the data
and ui of a storefront it was just
announced yesterday so let's put it to
the test and see if it's something we
would actually want to use but first
make sure to hit the like button and
subscribe and let me know what you think
about hydrogen in the comments your
first question might be what is the
point of hydrogen we already have next
js and gatsby both of which have
e-commerce templates and then shopify
itself already has a ton of e-commerce
themes so where exactly does hydrogen
come in well if you've ever built an
e-commerce site from scratch you'll know
that it's extremely difficult and that's
why platforms like shopify bigcommerce
and squarespace are very popular but at
the same time when you use a platform
like that your site has a tendency to
feel like a cookie cutter template and
it can be very hard to customize it
enough to break out of that the cool
thing about shopify is that it has a
graphql api allowing you to use it in a
headless way so hydrogen basically
provides a streamlined way to get a
server rendered frontend app up and
running that connects to your shopify
backend with minimal effort in other
words it provides a starting point for
building fully customizable storefronts
it's kind of like the ruby on rails for
shopify development and i only say that
because shopify itself was built with
ruby on rails now let's take a look at
the developer experience the website is
awesome and i actually really like the
name hydrogen it's not as cool as
prometheum but still way better than
arsenic create a new app by running npx
create hydrogen app when you open it
you'll see a project configured with a
lot of stuff here the starter template
it provides you with is definitely
opinionated you'll notice a shopify
config file you can swap out your own
shopify info here to use your own
products the next thing to notice is a v
config file it uses beat as the build
tool which i really like because it's
minimal easy to use and fast it also
comes with tailwind by default which i
think is an interesting choice i like
tailwind but at the same time it's
pretty polarizing and i don't think a
lot of people will actually want
tailwind i think plain css would have
been a better default but i can always
just go and build my own javascript
framework for something like that now
let's take a look at the server.js file
as you can see a hydrogen app is just an
expressjs app with some hydrogen
middleware and it even includes a docker
file that will run the server when you
deploy your app to production now the
application code itself is contained in
the source directory inside of which
you'll see a directory for components
and pages if we open components you'll
notice that some components end in dot
client while others end in dot server
that's because the framework is
leveraging server components in react i
talked about server components in my
recent next.js video but basically
they're just react components that can
fetch data and be rendered to plain html
on the server if we take a look at one
like the default seo component you can
see here that it makes a query to the
shopify graphql api but that query will
happen on the server allowing search
engine bots and social media link bots
to understand the content on the page
now one thing that's interesting here is
that there are a ton of pre-built
components in the framework that's a bit
unusual because most frameworks aren't
really concerned about the ui but
hydrogen feels more like a cross between
a template and a framework like you have
components for a shopping cart which you
can then go in and customize as needed
personally i feel a bit overwhelmed
looking at all these components but it's
just in developer preview and i imagine
they'll have a more minimal template in
the future now let's head over to the
pages directory which works just like
next js where the structure of the pages
determine the actual routes or urls in
the application i like this approach and
it's a lot easier than trying to
configure something like react router
what you'll notice in these pages is
that they use a custom hook from
hydrogen called use shop query the hook
takes a graphql query and will
automatically fetch that data from the
shopify api that makes it very clear and
easy to access the data that you need
for the ui and once again it's rendered
on the server giving you a search engine
friendly web app which is extremely
important for ecommerce now let's move
into my final analysis overall i think
hydrogen looks awesome primarily because
it looks very similar to next.js i think
the starting point is a little too
complex but i'm guessing they'll have
multiple different templates in the
future or maybe a cli where you can pick
and choose the features that you want
kind of like nuxjs and the vue ecosystem
i think my biggest question here is why
not just build this on top of next js
rather than build yet another javascript
framework
oh wait a second i figured it out
shopify will eventually have its own
hosting service called oxygen i'm not
sure if that'll be free or paid but it
looks like they're creating a model
similar to versailles where they provide
an open source framework that funnels
you into their own hosting service
there's nothing wrong with that just
something to be aware of what's more
interesting to me is that react server
components are going to make it way
easier for anybody to just create a
server rendered react app without
needing to rely on a bunch of weird
abstractions in the near future you
might just be able to build a simple
react app with server components then
deploy it to a node.js server and that
could lead to more javascript frameworks
like hydrogen that focus on domain
specific problems i'm going to go ahead
and wrap things up there let me know
what you think about hydrogen in the
comments thanks for watching and i will
see you in the next one